did you grow up in what you would call a
happy house was it I wouldn't I wouldn't
I wouldn't I mean it wasn't like turmoil
you know but it was uh there was a lot
of stress you know in the house it was
uh uh you know my parents were were
just getting by and yeah you know and
you know at the time as a kid I thought
we were doing great you know but in
retrospect you know I I talked to my mom
and learned like what she was making
every year and it was like nothing yeah
and I couldn't believe it yeah you know
and my dad he was always like you know
he he had this job when I was a kid he
worked for this toy company and the toy
company moved they decided to stay and
uh he was just bouncing around different
things yeah and then he started a
one-hour photo store and right before
the dawn of the digital age you know
like the worst timing and uh I know
it'll do it
yeah
yeah and I would you know I would go
there on weekends and I literally saw
the world changing through from the
perspective of that One Hour Photo Story
yeah yeah yeah
being a kid working at your parents
struggling family business
is something I am very well aware of
that I have plenty of experience with
yeah and if you don't know it you don't
know it it is a kind of like
it's like the first time I ever was in
an earthquake and I looked out the
window and I saw the street rolling yeah
like the ocean yeah the paved Street
look like the ocean and I still
questioned did I really see that wait
what's the business it was uh Building
Trades it was a stepfather had a
plumbing business and and then my mother
uh was in the kitchen remodeling and and
then she did Contracting too but got it
she was doing really really well for a
long time and it was in the Chicago
suburbs where people were building giant
Grand mcmansions yeah 30-foot foyers and
all yeah yeah and then you know just
downturns in the economy she had a
builder literally skipped the country
owing her money God yeah and you're just
there and you know you know nobody like
no my mom doesn't show me the books yeah
but I know oh this is bad yeah as a kid
you feel it you just feel it and it
feels like the Earth is going to fall
yeah this kind of
something that you relied on like your
parents just you know being steady and
taking care of you it's like oh my God
they're they could get swallowed up too
yeah yeah I mean as a kid I never fully
grasped that you know like I I I I would
hear them arguing down the hall you know
yeah and not really know what it was
about I'd just be in my bed just hearing
them arguing and you know and you know
come to find out later it was often
about money you know it was often about
like uh uh
trying to keep this house trying to keep
you know keep this family intact and uh
and it was you know and also the the you
know immigrants in this new country and
you know the pressures of having made
this move and then like finding it very
hard you know and I didn't grasp that so
much as a kid you know uh but uh as I
got older I was like oh my gosh that's
that's so tough yeah yeah do you think
they ever regretted coming here do you
think they think they thought like I
always should have just stayed in Korea
my mom how old were they when they came
here my dad was in his later 20s and my
mom was in her kind of earlier 20s and
they moved here together no oh well well
they met in Korea my dad moved here to
San Francisco lived in San Francisco
this is before my mom went back to Korea
met my mom who was in college and uh and
came back to uh uh L.A and then my mom
joined him in L.A like like a couple
years later yeah yeah after she finished
school and my mom was she told me not
too long ago maybe a couple years ago
that she was very depressed when she got
here you know uh because she didn't
speak the language yeah she didn't my
dad was working I think my dad had kind
of sold her on America as this kind of
magical place you know and she had
watched all the movies and seen you know
uh she really wanted to come to America
because of her vision of this country
was just like you know these
movies that she had seen and did you
know did she know people that had
preceded her to Los Angeles no oh okay
no that's a thing and my dad was the
first of his family so so uh and when
she got here my dad lived in this tiny
apartment and uh and was working all the
time was he at least around Korean
people uh not I mean our neighborhood
was where where I for you know was born
and first lived which is where they
lived was it wasn't like a Korean heavy
neighborhood it was like every everybody
else right but we'd go to Koreatown yeah
get our food and come back you know she
could get her fixed of people that
actually spoke her language yeah yeah
but she was very depressed she had these
two boys and she was in this tiny
apartment and and uh and you know as a
kid you don't you don't know what's
going on going on exactly but you feel
it you know you feel it and you you can
feel all those struggles and and then
over the years I I felt it you know but
uh but I wouldn't say it was like a a
tough childhood I mean they really they
really uh
did everything and they could to to give
me a semi-normal childhood and and it
felt pretty normal yeah yeah did that
create a situation for you where you
you felt like being around people that
were so kind of well like you said
depressed and yeah and stressed that it
made you want to make people happy like
was that did that because I because it
can go that way yeah you can also go
where like people draw onto themselves
you know but yeah I think that's a
fairly common thing growing up yeah sad
household yeah yeah I think so yeah I
think so for me and uh you know it
wasn't necessarily like
I think because I was born and raised
here and my parents were you know uh
raised in Korea and and it wasn't like I
was gonna make them laugh it wasn't like
that you know like my sensibility and
the things I love were not the same
things they loved right but I I do
remember uh always like always buying
them gifts and and even as a young kid
like oh oh her birthday's coming I gotta
make a really special gift for her you
know and them kind of not being that
into it I remember that you know like
like I do yeah like I'd save up like
five dollars to to get my dad this thing
and and and he'd be like why did you
spend that money you know like yeah and
it was like constant rejection you know
oh boy
well that's a good training oh perfect
training